dream review save with the kid's name
review and clapping with me
parents made everyone's favorite her
show welcome back everyone to your
highlight of the week meme review
youtube show oh I'm out of G fuel what
the frig
alright I'm gonna try and compose myself
despite the fact that I'm out of Jeep
god I need
now we're gonna start this off with some
wonderful minecraft memes y'all know
this would come up this week if you are
a fellow meme sir like I am
these minecraft memes are just blowing
up
[Music]
now I really like these minecraft memes
it's kind of surprises me that no one's
done this before the heck oh yeah that's
good that's good give me it makes you
laugh haha and this is that really what
memes all comes down to a good old ha ha
alright who's it going to be okay armor
helmet
o-64 oh my god see see what I mean it's
a nice meme hold me my god that rhyme I
don't like this one there don't like
this one delete this one get it out of
my sight Peter Griffin will never be
sans Peter Griffin will never be sane
I'm so done I'm just absolutely done
okay what the egg okay that's funny eggs
are funny is this how to basic him
alright everyone alright take it back
that's just disgusting
I'm sorry h3h3 I'm not calling you out
or anything what else do we got okay see
what I mean it's a good me it makes you
laugh it makes you go ha ha very nice I
like it that's a strong dog not supposed
to be my opinion where's the pity pie
one where I don't have any legs ha ha ha
ha
look at this one with Bob Rost oh that's
great so cute alright I haven't seen
this one two buckets that's great what a
great meet I'm gonna raid it but we
still have more memes ok freak yeah the
four horsemen of the mine pocalypse if
you see any of these then you best be on
making great haste cuz my god they
cannot be defeated
goddamn oh look at that I knew it
racism stop being so goddamn bigoted
Jesus Christ I'm gonna rake the
minecraft mean it's a solid seven ever
one next meme now I think it's worth
mentioning just how powerful the Ricardo
memes despite me reviewing them last
week
Ricardo memes is still going very strong
when you change your hide on tinder from
511 to six inches god damn holy Frick
top ten reasons why I hate white dog
number number five he's ugly and fat
don't talk about my boy white dog
no one Russian dashcam videos these
memes are just freaking everywhere first
of all why are they so many Russian dash
cam video
no.1 Russian dash cam video this is not
even Russia this is San Andreas with the
frame no.1 Russian dashcam video how the
freaky the tickity does that even happen
come on Russia get your act together are
you okay I like how Russia you're
allowed to say that no one cares but if
I went India now of course it's meme is
a variation of the literally no one XYZ
or whatever like no one youtubers stop
at a conniving youtubers it's really
hard being a youtuber okay so just stop
it
I feel personally offended by this now
moving back to no one Russian dashcam
videos no one Russian dash cam be what
the Freak what is happening in Russia
everyone I especially like this one no
one Xbox players
I'm Connery no one T Siri subscribers
I'm Connery
I know I can make means to nobody rush
and dashcam videos are you even trying
at this point like this is just news
footage like GE her father exists
PewDiePie this is my last and final
weapon against t-series I didn't want to
reveal my power this early in the game I
have a really large tongue watch
carefully t-series are you seeing this
t-series that's right t-series I think
I've proved my point here today I expect
you to run back and never look back
never come back from you're banished
from these lands t-series now of course
don't forget to enter the code PewDiePie
for 10% off G fuel it is very delish
nobody anime character with glasses I
really like this me I don't know why
adding nobody in front of a joke just
makes it funnier for some reason
literally no one Egyptian you want
perfect
no one youtubers reacting to something
hey wait a minute stop it right there
her do you eat ass alright well so bad
Jesus Christ parents why are you failing
your fun me listen I'll be honest with
you I'm kind of ready it's funny because
it's relatable for you you dumb balls
nobody Taiwanese dashcam videos damn
taiwanese come out of nowhere could
russia to shame
goddamn alright guys smash like and
subscribe if you're taiwanese and
there's a special breakfast for my
taiwanese bros absolutely no-one n-words
who post late-night Bart Simpson it's
funny because it's true get it no one
you
we're using a $15,000 PC to play for
tonight stop attacking izing youtubers
okay yeah I need a $15,000 computer to
record myself reacting to memes
any other questions now this is actually
a wonderful mean template of Bill Gates
that can lead to other wonderful
creations such as this one enemy boobs
the bra it's funny because it's true
using a calculator to make sure four
plus three equals seven on a test it's
funny because it's relatable for idiots
not for me of course I know that's seven
you can just add this to literally
anything how about this one
nobody brie Larson is that a personal
attack or something is that like a
personal attack or something literally
know what see I can make jokes to nobody
brie Larson it's this some kind of
attack damn it that was my joke all
right
this mean gets a 7.5 I actually really
like these cuz they that the multitudes
of this memes that's right that's a word
that I use can leave it to a lot of
different iterations I don't know
exactly what else this could go at this
point but of course that remains to see
in the future next mean these Tom and
Jerry memes has been all over dank meme
reddit and I feel like they deserve a
little mention for example it's pretty
much the same template now this text on
top reaction phase meme like that's what
I should have summarized at some me
drinks - yogurt samples from the samples
tray
woman working in the sperm donation
clinic what the Frick
you just drank sperm my dude that is
disgusting me having one last fling with
my girlfriend everyone else at her
funeral
uh that's necrophilia steals the heart
of a cute girl everyone else in the
surgery room why would you do that she's
going through surgery right now dude
what the all I get it Oh dad we need to
tell you something
your mother and I are siblings Alabama
Kane's calling
me trying to get the last spring from
the king
I can't believe I chuckle at that me
introduces girlfriend to family my wife
shouldn't like this one it's not a bad
mean it's one of those means you know
it's gonna be dead even before this
video goes up me puts porn on the TV
since my mom went shopping
Best Buy employee him I get it very
clever
this meme as much as I like it we'll get
two for Jimmy my same Thomson but that's
all you got for now bring it maybe in
the future and we can talk all right
another meme that has been popping up I
guess it's worthy of a mention it's that
go crazy but it's a meme so I'm not
gonna talk about it next up another mean
we have it's that this is how you look
like basically mean how is your mother
fast look when making minecraft memes
damn that one's got a burn that was
gonna cut hard how ya'll must look right
after watching Madagascar in three in
theaters how y'all in words look when
you play Minecraft in peaceful mode damn
y'all a bunch of clowns are you gonna
are you just gonna be okay with this
how y'all mother gosh look know what's
happening ah Oh y'all mom look with two
gigs of RAM damn damn that one's gonna
hurt that one savage dog Oh y'all look
saying she's actually a hundred how
y'all n-words look when you PK fire 32
times in a row wow you just had to act
them all right I don't think it's gonna
get any better hope you guys enjoyed
this video check out merch oh wait it's
finished bet you wish you bought it dumb
balls now that's it